the reason why you're not following
through is because you're doing it alone
when you wake up and you feel like you
are by yourself you are all alone you
have no Community you're not
collaborating you're not doing this with
anybody else it's just massively
difficult to follow through still
possible absolutely but this is the life
of an entrepreneur this is why so many
great entrepreneurs don't follow through
and it breaks my heart because you've
Got Talent you've got a desire to serve
and the help and you know you have a
story that matters you're just not as
consistent as you know you could be and
it's not that you suck it's just that
you're doing it alone